how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything marvel cinematic universe and
we only have a few more days until
the one division finale and for those of
you who were asking
the ninth episode is going to be the
finale there is no 10th
secret episode coming that was just a
rumor going around but marvel did
confirm today that episode 9
is going to be the finale and there are
still so many questions that the fans
want answers to including who exactly is
this
aerospace engineer monica rambo in the
middle of the season said that she knew
an aerospace engineer and we never met
that engineer
so who could this mysterious aerospace
engineer be
many fans were hoping for reed richards
and that is definitely a possibility
that we're going to talk about in this
video but who else could it possibly be
and could it also be paul bettany
trolling us
we'll break down every single character
that it could be in this video
but if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest one of vision or marvel videos
so for those of you who may not know
paul bettany teased that he worked with
an actor
in one division that he wanted to work
with for a very long time
he said that they worked very well
together and they had a lot of chemistry
together and that's really all he's said
since now we assumed that it was going
to be somebody older than him
or around the same age as him so we
assumed that it was most likely going to
be a villain maybe mephisto
nightmare but i now don't think those
characters are going to show up
now spoiler alert for wanda vision
episode 8 we saw the
white slash gray vision show up in the
post credit scene so was paul bettany
actually talking about himself
working with himself in one division
when one division director matt shackman
was asked about paul bettany's secret
cameo statement he said
i'm gonna let paul bettany answer that
question he dug himself
this whole he can get out of it now this
is pretty vague and doesn't really
answer any of our questions
but i would like to assume that paul
bettany wouldn't troll us that hard
and there is still this mysterious
aerospace engineer that we have yet to
see
so it looks like this cameo could be the
same person as the aerospace engineer
and not to mention elizabeth olsen did
say that there
is a luke skywalker level cameo coming
so let's hope that shows up in the
finale but in the meantime who could
this mysterious person be
well let's go over the list and we'll
start with the one that everybody wants
it to be
reed richards mr fantastic of the
fantastic four
now reed richards isn't just an
aerospace engineer he is
many different things and he is the
smartest person in all of marvel history
he's smarter than tony stark bruce
banner shuri
he's smarter than everybody and that's
why he's known as the smartest man
but part of his knowledge and what he
does is aerospace engineering he
actually built the spaceship that the
fantastic four went to space in and that
is definitely aerospace engineering so
to think that
reed richards of the fantastic four
could be this mysterious aerospace
engineer
is not wrong at all especially if you
consider this
only months ago kevin feige the
president of marvel studios during
disney's investor day
came out and announced that the
fantastic four is currently in
development and right now they are
working on
a feature this means that things are
rolling for the fantastic four
and they most likely have figured out
who they want to play mr fantastic
sue storm aka the invisible woman the
thing
and the human torch so if they have the
actors ready who are going to play the
fantastic four team
which it does seem like they do since
kevin feige said they're working on the
feature right now
it's entirely possible that john
krasinski perhaps could make an
appearance as mr fantastic
in one division and this could set up
the fantastic four for future films like
ant-man 3 and of course their own solo
film
now of course there are other huge
characters that could show up like
magneto or professor x which we'll talk
about in just a minute but another
person who could fit the title of
aerospace engineer
is blue marvel aka adam brasher
adam brasher is of super genius
intelligence and according to reed
richards mr fantastic himself adam's
intelligence matches dr dooms which is
pretty dang smart
now adam brasher is a genius in the
field of theoretical physics so he's not
exactly an aerospace engineer although
the mcu could
say that he is in fact an aerospace
engineer or that's part of what he does
kind of like mr fantastic he's a genius
all around but the big connection here
is not only the fact that he's a genius
it's the fact that adam brasher
actually is in a relationship with
monica rambo in the comics
so this would make perfect sense monaco
rambo knows an aerospace engineer
this aerospace engineer could be
somebody that she is romantically
involved with and it could very well be
adam brasher this would introduce yet
another
new superhero to the marvel cinematic
universe blue marvel
however there is yet another genius out
there that i don't think
a lot of people have been talking about
who could be this mysterious aerospace
engineer and that is hank mccoy aka
beast hank mccoy is actually one of the
eight smartest people in the marvel
universe
and not a lot of people realize this
hank mccoy has six phds
he has designed and built cerebra for
professor x and he's designed and built
a time machine
and not to mention that he's the x-men's
resident technological and medical
genius
and this does include working on the
x-jet
meaning that he is somewhat of an
aerospace engineer again in the mcu they
could kind of say that he's anything
one of his phds could be in aerospace
engineering so he could definitely be
the aerospace engineer and if you are
looking to introduce the x-men into the
mcu this would be kind of a perfect way
to do it kevin feige did say that one
division could be a gateway to the
x-men and in one of vision episode 8 we
found out that wanda actually had powers
all along meaning that she could have
had the x gene inside of her this whole
entire time and mutants could already
exist in the marvel cinematic universe
so if you don't want to go down the
route of wanda created the mutants with
her hex but in fact they were in the mcu
this whole time this would be a great
way to introduce the mutants by
introducing hake mccoy aka beast
now let's go ahead and act like paul
bettany wasn't talking about this
engineer perhaps we'll never see this
engineer even if it is reed richards
maybe they'll just drop his name but we
won't actually see him
so let's assume the engineer and the
cameo that paul bettany is talking about
from the idol that he wants to work with
is a different person
right now the two best bets for the
actors and characters showing up are
patrick stewart's professor xavier and
in mckellen's magneto
now if we're going to go the multiverse
route this would make sense that one of
these two actors would show up
we know that kevin feige met with
patrick stewart about reprising his role
as professor xavier in the mcu
now patrick stewart said that he
declined stating that he said goodbye to
his character in logan
but that's because he didn't want to
undo the character's death
however if the multiverse is going to be
involved which we know it will be
because we are getting doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness and one
division does lead
up right to it then patrick stewart
could definitely return and reprise his
role as professor xavier one last time
for a secret cameo
now we say professor xavier because
patrick stewart already met with kevin
feige however what makes the most sense
is
magneto in the comics who wanda's
parents are are actually kind of a big
deal
she finds out that the parents who
raised her aren't her actual parents
and in one storyline it was revealed
that magneto was her father
and considering how great of an actor
ian mckellen is it would make sense that
paul bettany would want to work with him
or patrick stewart
i should also note that al pacino is
somebody that paul bettany has said that
he's always wanted to work with so
it could be him playing a mysterious
character that we don't know
and of course again there is always the
fact that paul bettany could simply be
trolling us and he could be talking
about himself we're on the finale now
and it's hard to imagine that they're
going to add
more characters into this since we don't
even have a final battle yet
but we have to remember that there is a
post credit scene
and this could very well be when we see
this surprise secret cameo
and since one division connects to
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and spider-man no way home we
can probably assume that it's going to
set one of those two movies up
i personally am hoping for either reid
richards or magneto to show up but let
me know who you would like to see
in the comments down below who do you
think is going to show up or do you
think
paul bettany was talking about himself
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest mcu news don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof